hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one of the
tendencies of modern civilization that
Fyodor Dostoevsky is criticizing through
the mouth of his interlocutor in notes
of the underground is represented by the
image of the Crystal Palace and there
actually was a crystal palace that
Dostoevsky himself did in fact get to
see that somebody had built at that time
the idea behind the Crystal Palace is
that it's a it's a perfect work true
transparency model of Engineering and
physics something that would emblem eyes
or symbolize what it is that that human
beings could do and transform themselves
as individuals and as members of society
into a purely harmonious system in which
everything would have its place
everything would be balanced ordered
proper and Dostoevsky has his character
say I don't actually want a Crystal
Palace like that and I think a lot of
other people don't including some of the
people who are its greatest advocates
and so let's take a look at the mindset
this dream we could say
rationalists the humanitarians the
social reformers and indeed of the
entire enlightenment project so he talks
about the problem you know why do people
do all the stupid things that they do
why is society so badly organized we're
always that counter purposes with each
other you can think about this just in
terms of like traffic you know driving
on the highway or negotiating your path
through the elevator or anything like
that in that crowded building why do
people do the things that they do you
know why why didn't this person like
drive slow in the fast lane causing you
know everybody else to have to go around
them don't they understand that they're
you know screwing up the system and so
the idea behind these reformers is
whatever aspect of life it happens to be
we can we can show people where there
are true interests and advantages lie
and if we do that they're no longer
gonna behave in the ways that they do
you know we would we would actually help
them he says you know man does nasty
things just because they don't know
where their real interests lie if they
were enlightened about it they would
immediately stop acting like pigs and be
kind and Noble being enlightened they
would see where their advantage later
then it lay in acting virtuously and you
know there's lots of different projects
and you know schemes for how to do this
as a matter of fact you could say that
one of the key aspects of the
Enlightenment as a cultural movement is
the generation of idea after idea after
idea a system after system of here's
here's what the ideal situation is going
to look like and how we're going to get
there what the blueprint is and so he
talks about you know what we would do
and he says that science common-sense
humanitarianism all these things can
actually rework us human beings and he
says that there's no doubt in your mind
that human beings will learn as soon as
they've gotten rid of certain old bad
habits when common sense and science
have completely re-educated human nature
and directed along the proper channels
you he's addressing the utopians seemed
certain that man himself will give up
airing of his free will and will stop
opposing his will to his interests you
say that science itself will teach man
that he has neither will nor whim never
had as a matter of fact that he's
something like a piano key or an organ
stop that there are on the other hand
natural laws in the universe whatever
happens to him happens outside of his
will as it were by itself in accordance
with the laws of nature so then all we
need to do is discover those laws and
man will no longer be responsible for
his acts life will be really easy for
him then all human acts will be listed
in something like log of the rhythm
tables stay up to the number 108
thousand and transfer it into a
timetable or better still catalogs will
appear designed to help us in the way
our dictionaries and encyclopedias do
they will carry detailed calculations
and exact forecasts of everything to
come so that no adventure and no action
will remain possible in the world what
is he talking about there well we're
going to examine the human being and
totally make sense out of them we're
gonna use science we're gonna say you
know are our ways of categorizing so
sort of logic applied we're gonna look
at their practical action and reasoning
and we're gonna fix it all this is still
a dream today as a matter of fact the
people who are big proponents of
technology seem to think that you can
take technology and apply it directly to
the human condition and we can you know
make things so much better as a matter
of fact has become kind of a silly trope
within the tech industry you know that
that we're making the world a better
place with its algorithm by you know
nudging people in this way or that way
based on neuroscience right most of the
stuff that purports itself to be neuro
anything out there is just kind of a
pasteboard cobbled together things with
all terms a hat ad-hoc assumptions
may not actually hold up there is some
some real neuroscience going on but that
often doesn't make such great fanfares
it's almost as if there's a little bit
of a digression here almost as if human
beings need to talk themselves into
thinking that these utopian schemes
aren't actually BS and will hold up to
real scrutiny while making sure that
never there never really is any real
scrutiny applied to them now coming back
to Dostoevsky what would we do we would
we would change things in such a way
that people would stop desiring the
wrong things we would inform them we
would reshape them we would guide their
desires and their formation and their
habits and take away the old wrongheaded
associations and over time we would
create a much better society in which
everybody could flourish we could say as
it were there might even be room he says
for you know chaos swearing and all of
that sort of stuff maybe there could be
a calculation for that so or a
calculation would prevent it so that
sanity would prevail and we could have
everybody you know getting exactly
what's good for them in in that respect
right now what if that were to happen
Dostoevsky doesn't actually think that
you're going to manage to pull this off
but let's just say it did let's say that
you had all of these resources and you
started changing human beings and you
managed to change human nature he says
well when desire merges with reason then
we will reason instead of desiring all
our desires and all of our reasoning
once they can be computed for the day is
bound to come and we'll understand what
governs what we now describes our free
will then we may really have some sort
of tables to guide our desires like
everything else so if a man sticks his
tongue out at someone it's because he
cannot not stick his tongue
that person and he has to hold his angle
at exactly that pet has had at that
angle so we would stop actually desiring
and in the way that we feel ourselves to
desire and we would just follow sort of
the laws of nature very complicated laws
you know what we might call
psychological or sociological laws these
generalizations you know as we get to
know more about the brain and more about
human interaction we could come up with
this incredibly complex system that we
could perhaps put into a predictive AI
and then it would we wouldn't even need
really to do all those things the AI
could model it for us right the result
is that we'd have no freedom no freedom
in any real sense we'd keep doing the
same things that we do but we wouldn't
be doing them as free beings what effect
would that have Dostoevsky says that
would leave no room for what it is that
humans really want what elsewhere he's
called the most advantageous advantage
which is to design decide for oneself
and desire for oneself and to to will
and have wins and and to express one's
own individuality even if that innovate
and individuality kind of sucks all that
would be left out of this would be
excluded there'd be no room for it and
he goes on he says well that would be a
very boring existence you know this
would not be a fun way to live this
would be dull and you know there's a
secondary problem there well what
happens when people get bored while they
do stupid things well we'd somehow
exclude that with these arrangements and
algorithms and orderings and tables and
charts so they wouldn't even be allowed
to be bored now there's another thing
that those two ASCII has to say about
this that's really quite interesting
and with the pull some of the
consequences I would read between the
lines on this he says so far these are
nothing but assumptions on your part
I'll grant you they conform to the laws
of logic but are they in accordance to
the human law in case you think I'm
crazy let me explain I agree that man is
a creative animal doomed to strive
consciously towards the goal engaged in
full-time engineering as it were so he's
saying we are teleologically driven so
you know we can in fact have our
interests and advantages explained to us
somebody can say oh well you want to
learn how to play guitar maybe the best
way to do it for you is not actually
watching videos on the internet maybe
you need to take some guitar lessons
with somebody or you get yourself a book
or do this or do that right we have a
teleological explanation then we can say
well why do you want to learn guitar
well I want to learn to shred man oh
okay if that's what you had in mind well
then you don't necessarily need to learn
this stuff you need to learn this stuff
and said I want to play you know
flamenco music oh well then you have to
do a lot of finger exercises and this
would be helpful for you right we can do
that sort of thing oh I want to play in
a band oh well then you probably need to
actually start talking with other people
who might someday want to play with you
and start learning how to jam rather
than perform simply on your own right we
go on and on and on
Dostoevsky goes further with this he
says we are engaged in full-time
engineering busy building ourselves
roads that lead somewhere never mind
where perhaps if he feels like straying
now and then it is just because he's
doomed to build this road that the road
goes somewhere and the main thing is not
where it goes but keeping the
well-meaning babe at his engineering
chores saving him from the deadly snares
of idleness we like creating and
building roads why then do we like chaos
and disorder and destruction he says
well perhaps it's because we're
instinctively afraid of reaching the
goal that we
are working for how do you know perhaps
that he likes his objective only from a
distance
perhaps he only likes to contemplate it
not to live in it
preferring to leave it when it comes
down to it to animals such as ants sheep
and such right
ants are different they have their their
anthill and they follow their
programming and they do it real nice and
yeah you know it's amazing what they can
do but we're not ants we're not simply
programmed devices or animals
he says the purpose is life itself and
not the goal which of course must be
nothing but two plus two equals four so
he loves the achieving he says but does
not particularly enjoy what he achieves
isn't that funny well human beings are
comical animals now let's think about
that so we'd be more interested in the
doing than the goal itself and we'd be
driven by our desires in ways that are
sometimes irrational could you apply
that to the goal of the Enlightenment
maybe even the people that are for the
Enlightenment when they start getting
closer to it and they start seeing their
dream becoming a reality aren't quite so
happy with what they're seeing and start
finding ways to drag their heels and
dither around and not make the progress
that they want to make or get themselves
a stupid personality conflicts or find
other ways to you know break the crystal
palace and send it tumbling down so they
can rebuild it again maybe that's what
really lies behind this dream of the
rationalist because think about it if it
was actually achieved we would lose an
integral part of human nature we would
lose our freedom we would become bored
with that and we wouldn't even be
allowed to express our boredom by
breaking things or making punk music or
something like that right
listening you know doing the thing
putting the guitar too close to the amp
and playing around with the feedback no
no you mustn't do that sort of thing
there's either either at work which is a
possibility for us and that's gonna be a
bad possibility or this whole thing is
really more irrational
that it pretends itself to be so those
are Dostoevsky is reflections on this
desire to turn the human being into
something like a set of organ stops or a
set of algorithms something that can be
predicted something that can be measured
something that can be improved upon
indefinitely until we reach the limit
point of perfect humanity
Dostoevsky is saying that is a project
that's doomed to fail by its own nature
and the more that it doesn't fail the
worse off we actually are
you